we're asked to graph y is equal to log
base 5 of X and just to remind us what
this is saying this is saying that y is
equal to the power that I have to raise
5 to to get to X or if I were to write
this logarithmic equation as an
exponential equation 5 is my base Y is
the exponent that I have to raise my
base 2 and then X is what I get when I
raise 5 to the Y power so another way of
writing this equation would be 5 to the
Y power to the Y power is going to be
equal to is going to be equal to X these
are the same thing here we have Y as a
function of X here we have X as a
function of Y but they're really saying
the exact same thing raised 5 to the Y
power to get X this when you put as a
logarithm you're saying well what power
do I have to raise 5 to to get X we'll
have to raise it to Y here what what do
I get when I raise 5 to the Y power I
get X now that out of the way let's make
ourselves a little bit a little table
that we can use to plot some points and
then we can connect the dots to see what
this curve looks like so let me pick
some X's in some Y's some X's and some
Y's and we in general want to pick some
numbers that give us some nice round
answers some nice fairly simple numbers
for us to deal with so that we don't
have to get a calculator and so in
general you want to pick x values you
want to pick X values where the power
that you have to raise 5 to to get that
x value is a pretty straightforward
power or another way to think about it
you could just think about the different
Y values that you want to raise that you
want to raise 5 to the power of and then
you can get your X values so we could
actually think about this one to come up
with to come up with our actual X values
but we want to be clear that when we
when we express it like this the
independent variable is X and the
dependent variable is y we might just
look at this one to pick some nice even
or nice nice X's that give us nice clean
answers for y so what happens so here
I'm actually going to fill in the Y
first just so that we get nice clean
exes so let's say we're going to raise
five to the let's say we're going to
raise it I'm going to pick some new
colors negative two negative two power
and let me do some other colors negative
one zero and then one I'll do one more
and then two so once again this is a
little bit on this little
non-traditional where I'm filling in the
dependent variable first but the way
that we've written it over here it's
actually given the dependent variable
it's easy to figure out what the
independent variable needs to be for
this logarithmic function so what X
gives me a Y of negative two what X
gives me what what does X have to be for
Y to be equal to negative two
well 5 to the negative 2 power is going
to be equal to X so 5 to the negative 2
is 1 over 25 so we get 1 over 25 so
another way if we go back to this
earlier one if we say log base 5 of 1
over 25 what power do I have to raise 5
to to get 1 over 25 we'll have to raise
it to the negative 2 power or you could
say 5 to the negative 2 is equal to 1
over 25 these are saying the exact same
thing now let's do another one what
happens when I raise 5 to the negative 1
power well I get one I get 1/5 so if we
go to this original one over there we're
just saying that log base 5 of negative
sign of 1/5 want to be careful this is
saying what power do we have to raise 5
to in order to get 1/5 we'll have to
raise it to the negative 1 power here
what power what happens when I take 5 to
the 0th power I get 1 I get 1 and so
this relationship this is the same thing
as saying log base 5 of 1 what power to
have to raise 5 to to get 1 well I just
have to raise it to the 0th power let's
do the next 2 what happens when I raise
5 to the first power well I get 5 so if
you go look over here that's just saying
log what power do I have to raise 5 to
to get 5 we'll have to just raise it to
the first power and then finally if I
take 5 squared I get 25
five so you when you look at it from the
logger and the point of view you say
well what power do I have to raise 5 to
to get to 25 we'll have to raise it to
the second power so I kind of took the
inverse of the logarithmic function I
wrote it as an exponential function I
switch to the dependent and independent
variables so I could pick so I can
derive nice clean X's that will give me
nice clean y's now with that either way
but I do want you to remind I could have
just I I could have just picked random
numbers over here but then I would have
probably gotten less clean numbers over
here I would have had to use a
calculator the only reason why I did it
this way is so I get nice clean results
that I can plot by hand
so let's actually graph it let's
actually graph this thing over here so
the Y's go between negative 2 & 2 the
X's go from 125th all the way to 25 so
let's let's graph it so so that is my
y-axis that is my y-axis and this is my
x-axis so I'll draw it like that that is
my x-axis and then the Y's start at 0
then you get to positive 1 positive 2
and then you have negative 1 and you
have negative 2 and then on the x axis
it's all positive and I'll let you think
about whether whether the domain here is
well we can think about it can is this
is the logarithmic function defined for
an X that is that is not positive so is
there any power that if that I could
raise 5 to that I could get 0 no you
could you could raise 5 to an infinitely
negative power to get a very very very
small number that approaches zero but
you can never get there's no power that
you can raise 5 to to get zero so X
cannot be 0 and there's no power that
you can raise 5 to to get a negative
number so X can also not be a negative
number so the domain of this function
right over here and this is relevant
because we want to think about what
we're graphing the domain here is X has
to be greater than 0 let me write that
down the domain here is that X has to be
greater than 0 so we're only going to be
able to graph this
function in the positive in the positive
x-axis so with out-of-the-way X gets as
large as 25 so let me graph let me put
those points here so that is 5 10 15 20
and 25 and then let's plot these so the
first one is in blue when X is 1 20 50
when X is 1 25th so 1 is there 1
twenty-fifths going to be really close
to there then y is negative 2 so it's
going to be like right over there not
quite at the y-axis we're at 125th to
the right of the y-axis but pretty close
so that's right over there that is 1
over 25 comma negative 2 right over
there then when X is 1/5 which is
slightly further to the right 1/5 Y is
negative 1 so right over there
so this is 1/5 negative 1 and then when
X is 1 Y is 0 so 1 might be right of
there so this is the point 1 0 and then
when X is 5 when X is 5 y is 1 when X is
5 I cover it over here but this is 5 y
is 1 Y is 1 so that's the point 5 1 and
then finally when X is 25 y is 2 when X
is 25 Y is 2 y is 2 so this is 25 comma
2 and then I can graph the function and
I'll do it let me do it in a color I
haven't used this pink so as X as X gets
soup or soup or soup or soup or small Y
goes to negative infinity
it gets really some Y to get to get X's
or as X becomes you know if you say what
power do you have to raise you have to
raise 5 to to get you know point zero
zero zero one has to be very very very
negative power so Y is going to get very
negative as we approach as we approach
zero and then it kind of moves up like
that and then starts to kind of curve to
the right like that so that is and this
thing right over here is going
keep going down and ever in creative at
a steeper and steeper rate and it's
never going to [ __ ] quite touch it's
never going to quite touch the y-axis
it's going to get closer and closer to
the y-axis but it's never going to quite
touch it